big X the plug Rama I'm going to let you
introduce your new artist introduce
yourself man for the people yeah Hood
man it's the B man y know what the [__]
going
on n
n no limit on
the oh man big ax you my my most
listened to artist on Spotify this year
did you see that when I did the recap I
did see that it was like you and jelly
roll and uh I don't even know who else
but but yeah man [__] congrats on
this new record this new record is going
crazy I saw you first of all this the
first time you hit the Billboard 100
right a record yeah I didn't hit the he
heat secer one right right but I'm
talking about like the top 100 songs in
the country yeah yeah I think it's like
60 64 right there something like yeah
congrats how's that
feel I be I don't be knowing what none
of this [__] really mean I just be I'm
working I just work y'all been working
non-stop for for like a year and a half
album Dro Deluxe album Dro tour tour
happens we did three tours it's just
going crazy like I I got to see you guys
in your live show uh when you guys hit
LA and it was definitely a Vibe man um
have you had any opportunity to like
take a break relax a little and smell
the flowers Noe no but it's like this
what we ask for so we ain't complaining
about it that's what I tell everybody
cuz I be stressed all the time yeah cuz
I got all kinds of businesses the
podcast the radio show and I always just
say hey man heavy heavy is the crown man
this what I asked for got to take care
of all this back home but you constantly
on the road it's it's it's it's it's
work but like I said it's what we signed
up for I just had a conversation with uh
my boy from Warner Records and he was
like yo every week we have a meeting
about this nle record that's streaming
like crazy and uh and every nobody in
these meetings it said me know who big X
to plug in what and I'm like what who's
in these [__] meetings but that
record is like doing really [__] well
my yes big shout out to Cho man I don't
even know I don't know where he got my
number from but he called me one day and
was just like hey I heard you going
crazy I'm trying to get you him
something he sent it I ran it and super
nice guy yeah yeah no he cool he cool he
cop me after it Dro was like you know
whatever you need let me know any tours
you got I need to pop up on just let me
know I got
so yeah we definitely we locked in we
shout out to n like I said I'm about to
say it's got to be like uh at this
moment in time very very um your inbox
has got to be booming for features for
people trying to work with you I mean
yeah if for like for a short period of
time that it was cool but like now it's
like I don't want to overdo myself so
I'm not doing every feature no more cuz
it's like it's got to be the [__] that
makes sense [__] you want exactly
exactly so yeah yeah but yeah if it was
good it was good the get was good while
it was but no we we we trying to
preserve oursel we trying to be in it
for a little minute we so you guys are
the Sha and Kobe obviously sha and Kobe
right yeah why not the Durk and kid or
the you know what the Luca Kyrie you're
right we are the Dirk and who you say
Jason kid madebe who else was on the M
back then on that ring team Jason Terry
no he didn't stop it was more than it
was more than two people though who was
on the Mavericks in 2011 it was who whoa
whoa whoa Jason kid somebody say Sean M
and I don't want to had a shot somebody
else can had a shot he hey no but his
shot he was on the
Suns oh I'll be I'll be Tyson Chandler
no I'm Dirk I'm Dirk I'm sorry I'm Dirk
was p on that team you Jason Terry no no
he would but he was on one of those
teams that didn't yeah not Jason Terry
well you got to be Jason kid he ends up
being the coach one of the greatest
point guards of all time and then that's
that's Jason
Jason Terry six man I like that yeah
[__] upset in Lebron so talk to me
about 600 obviously Rose uh going crazy
you guys have been I feel like y'all Dro
so much music I'm like and what's crazy
is we haven't we haven't we don't only
we we've only dropped what maybe four
songs together but like in the last like
six months in the last 6 months we've
dropped still F two it's two and then
your project is obviously not a full
project it's like a EP yeah that was
just that was just a little something on
some I really had just been telling my
team and I ain't dropped in so long
right I got to drop something and we had
just went to Phoenix we was out there in
Phoenix for like two oh yeah you guys
were at the Airbnb out there recording
cooking up so being racially
profiled yeah we ain't even going to
speak on that though you know we better
times you know but uh either way go yeah
we made a bunch of bangers then so I
just decided to to put some of them on a
little EP just thank God you did cuz one
your biggest records so far is on it
right yeah yeah for sure and you know
what's crazy I actually dropped that
song before the EP even came out it kind
of was just like a build up to the EP
and they didn't want me to drop it oh no
we didn't we didn't have enough time to
promote it set everything up for it I
said [__] that we got to do something
yeah they they they begging for it and
so I'm curious crazy like uh are are you
still with United Masters still in prend
is that is that something that you ever
are going to entertain cuz everybody lot
people been asking me that they want to
give you I'm I'm sure there's a big bag
out there for you if you want it but it
just got to it got to make oh what comes
with that you know like what comes with
the bag cuz you go get a bag No Matter
What obviously we my manager just called
one of my managers just called me
yesterday asked me the same question I
told him look as long as I still got the
the better half of my masters cuz I
don't care about the The Upfront Bay cuz
I Advance is short minded money exactly
I don't care about that I need to know
that at the end of the day I can for one
buy myself out M and for two that I have
the majority of my man I think I think
he said 21 Savage is uh who who 21
Savage was with Brandon EP epic and it's
a 910 you see what I'm saying like
that's great and it's like that makes
sense yes he got a 910 he has a 910 [__]
good for him but it's like he went with
he went that's how he beat he beat that
immigration charge he had all that money
on to spend ony hand when he went into
that so like I probably can do that
right now but it's like now I'm looking
at a bigger picture you know what I'm
saying so I'm really looking for they
got to give you the label exactly they
got to bring the label over and so
that's what we're trying to do right now
if if something come my way and and and
it makes sense then cool but if not this
is my focus right now well I was going
to ask for you like uh what is obviously
being on the road with him working with
him so much when is your next body of
work going to be coming uh see we got
the tape coming out so sh we I'm on
there joint tape yeah 600 tape so oh
it's gonna be like a compilation like a
label compation Sixers oo meet the
Sixers yeah you guys pay homage to a lot
of teams that aren't the
Mavericks but it's no it's not even the
team I know I know I'm just [__] with
you 600 I get I get it I get it but it's
like an ultimate ego like we since we've
been on the road man it's just been some
crazy ass moments going y got to get
that merch looking good man I just got
the logo and everything made it's on the
way it's on the way but yeah man that's
that's all ego and so it's just I don't
know I just feel like it's a lot of
different flavors between the three of
us and so it just it got crazy on every
song We Do